a two-week lockdown has been imposed in
sydney to contain an outbreak of the
highly contagious covert 19 delta
variant
the new restriction of restrictions
affect more than 5 million people in and
around the australian city
at least 80 cases have been reported so
far
most have been linked to a limousine
driver who was infected while taking an
international flight crew
to a quarantine hotel the country
remains largely unvaccinated
here's what the state premier had to say
during the lockdown announcement
a few days ago i said this was the
scariest time that i felt
since the pandemic started and that's
proven to be the case
we should brace ourselves for more cases
we're finding
that all household contacts
unfortunately getting the virus
transmissibility is at least double what
previous variants have been
so we do need to brace ourselves for
potentially larger number of cases in
the following days and that's why
it's so important we take action now
let's get the latest from sydney with
journalist roger maynard
roger a lockdown for millions because of
some 80 new virus cases
i mean for those of us living in europe
or elsewhere that seems rather strict
why
are the authorities taking this strict
action
yeah the figures are quite low by global
standards but
they were enough to scare the new south
wales government into
serious action and declaring a total
lockdown of sydney
um from today and for the next two weeks
the deciders are being
urged to stay at home unless they need
to go out for shopping or
have essential work to attend to which
they can't do at home or need a bit of
exercise
um shops can stay open but uh cafes are
only being allowed to serve
takeaways um the weddings will be
allowed tomorrow but after then uh
no more weddings for at least a
fortnight and as for funerals well
they can continue as long as no more
than
100 mourners are uh are attending but
generally speaking it's uh it's a pretty
uh serious development here
and reflects the the serious nature or
the serious view that the government
are taking of the situation now it's
largely the delta variant that seems to
be present there is that correct why are
authorities
so worried about the delta variant well
the state government have taken you know
what's
really a fairly draconian action because
they they fear there's every chance of
the delta strain of the virus
spreading uncontrollably around the city
the new south wales health minister uh
said today that this variant is
already moving around the community far
faster than
anyone could have imagined and there are
very real fears that
uh more cases many more cases could
emerge
in the coming days so it seems that
sydney signers are getting the message
pretty quickly today
roads were practically deserted with
traffic um the
pedestrians were more or less absent
completely from the city center
and uh you know australia it has to be
said has been fairly fortunate since
this pandemic began
partly because uh it's an island at the
far end of the world but
also because the government closed the
international border last march
and uh all returning australian citizens
had to undergo
two weeks mandatory quarantine in a
hotel so australia's
escape the full brunt of the pandemic
but risks or worries about
it uh starting now what about
vaccinations roger i mean the
vaccination rollout got off to a slow
start how are vaccinations coming along
now
yeah well the the vaccination roller is
still pretty slow it has to be said
but the latest figures are about only
five percent of the population have had
only one
jab uh and that's partly because of the
shortage of supplies the the government
didn't order enough uh to begin with
and then there's vaccine hesitancy a lot
of the vaccinations at the moment are
astrozenica
people worried about blood clots
associated with the estrogenic
virus and as a result of that a lot of
people deciding that they
they won't take the jab now they'll wait
till uh supplies of
fires start arriving in greater quantity
and have the jab then so there's a lot
of vaccine hesitancy and that's one
reason
why the vaccination rollout hasn't
happened as quickly as it might have
done
meanwhile the economic cost of this
two-week lockdown is expected to be at
least two billion dollars
and uh if the outbreak continues then
the uh the lockdown
could be extended well beyond that all
right roger thank you very much roger
maynard journalist in sydney
you